bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8 une
nouvelle semaine et comme chaque soir
une heure en direct pour faire le point
sur l'actualité locale en direct entre
18 et 19 heures dans un instant nous
reviendrons sur la situation du logement
ou plutôt du mal logement la fondation
abbé pierre a rendu son rapport en fin
de semaine dernière rapport annuel et
les réactions en plateau de solidarités
nouvelles pour le logement association
de saint quentin en yvelines deux de ses
représentants sont déjà avec nous mais
pour le moment voici les titres de ce 4
février la mobilisation contre le
mariage pour tous se poursuit après les
partisans et les opposants à la réforme
à nouveau dans la rue samedi des
manifestations avaient lieu dans chaque
département à versailles ils étaient
entre 15 et 22 milles pour dire tout
simplement non à compter de ce lundi les
diabétiques des yvelines vont recevoir
un courrier de la cpam des yvelines pour
leur proposer d'adhérer gratuitement au
dispositif baptisé sofia un dispositif
d'accompagnement dans l'agglomération
trappe et la verrière sont les communes
les plus concernées par cette maladie
chronique
l'explication également sur le plateau
avec une responsable de la cpam le monde
des dinosaures qui s'invite à la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
pour le plaisir évidemment des enfants
qui découvrent à travers un quiz
l'univers des diplodocus et autres
animaux préhistoriques et puis mélissa
mahieu elle a 14 ans elle est inscrite
au club de baseball des cougars de
montigny elle collectionne les titres de
meilleure lanceuse un parcours fulgurant
qui pourrait l'emmener jusqu'aux états
unis
elle son portrait sera à découvrir au
cours du 7-8 sport 26 minutes pour faire
un point complet sur l'essentiel des
résultats du week end mais pour
l'instant le fait du jour
le fait du jour c'est donc la
mobilisation qui se poursuit et même
s'intensifient autour du projet de loi
de mariage pour tous et ce chiffre 15000
chiffres du jour ils étaient quinze
mille à versailles samedi selon la
police à défiler parmi les personnalités
présentes et christine bouquet boutin
conseillère générale des yvelines
présidente du parti chrétien démocrate
et puis henri guaino député ump de la 3e
circonscription
le reportage de claire cambier de
guillaume cambis leurs armes la rue et
manifestons contre le mariage pour tous
l'ont envahie en nombre samedi dernier
date de l'adoption par l'assemblée
nationale du premier article de la loi
incriminée quinze mille manifestants
selon la police 22 mille selon les
organisateurs
le rassemblement à versailles était
d'ailleurs le plus important au niveau
national parmi eux des responsables des
différentes communautés religieuses car
leur croyance ne serait pas compatible
avec le mariage pour tous pour nous on
va dire il ya deux types d'orphelins et
à l'orphelin qui quémandent la tragédie
humaine il a perdu son père il a perdu
sa mère et il y à l'orphelin qui le
nouvel emplâtre que l'institution
précieuse va pondre aujourd'hui c'est
l'institution violente de la
constitution à savoir que lampard va
demain chercher son père ou sa mère
selon le cas il va pas le trouver
au delà du mariage homosexuel c'est donc
surtout la question de l'enfant qui
mobilise les communautés musulmane
catholique et protestante refuse le
droit à l'adoption par les couples
homosexuels et craignent d'éventuelles
des vignes
je suis là parce qu'on sait très bien
que cette loi une fois qu'elle sera
votée et bien ouvrira la voie à la
procréation médicalement assistée pour
les femmes est logiquement par égalité
des droits les hommes demanderont la
gestation pour autrui et là dans les
deux cas on est dans l'adoption qui
n'est pas une vraie attention et on est
dans la marchandisation du corps humain
la circulaire de madame taubira est la
preuve par neuf
malgré tous ces mensonges que là que la
gpa et est au programme
c'est évident le gouvernement a
cependant rappelé la semaine dernière
que la gestation pour autrui n'était pas
à l'agenda du quinquennat peu convaincu
8000 croyants et laïque ont signé en
marge du rassemblement une pétition
nationale lancé par le maire divers
droite du chéné philippe brillault si le
nombre de 500 mille signataires est
atteint le conseil économique social et
environnemental devra étudier la
recevabilité de la loi toujours sur ce
sujet on écoute à présent henri guaino
député ump de la 3e circonscription des
yvelines il est l'un des principaux
opposants à ce projet à l'assemblée il
demande toujours un référendum et
surtout il estime que peu importe
l'avancée des discussions entre députés
il faut continuer à mobiliser on écoute
tout n'est pas perdu
la république jusqu'au dernier moment
décidé de soumettre cette loi à
référendum
donc voilà au peuple de le lui réclame
côté socialiste certaines voix s'élèvent
afin de demander plus de réflexion c'est
le cas de jean philippe mallet le député
de la 11e circonscription il avait
d'ailleurs évoqué pendant un temps des
états généraux on les écoute au micro
d'anthony rech
je les dis au président du groupe
socialiste bruno le roux au ministre
bertinotti et est au bir a donc d'abord
en interne mais également publiquement
j'ai des réserves sur ce projet de loi
je pense que c'est un dossier une
question anthropologique importante et
pour ce type de dossier jeu il ya une
sorte de liberté de conscience comme
l'avait dit le président devant
l'assemblée des maires et romance est
important donc j'ai effectivement des
réserves quant à ceux à ce projet de loi
pour l'instant vous mettra en voir aux
visions et prix ou un jour je jeu très
certainement je ne le voterai pas